[Music]
on my orders Coalition forces have begun
striking selected targets of military
importance to undermine Saddam Hussein's
ability to wage war
we welcome you back to CBS mornings with
the moment that President George W bush
announced the U.S had invaded Iraq back
in 2003 nearly 20 years ago today the
justification at the time that Saddam
Hussein had weapons of mass destruction
those weapons of course famously and
consequentially were never found and
while Iraqi operation Iraqi Freedom led
to the fall of saddam's brutal regime it
also cost the lives of around 4 500
American Service members and hundreds of
thousands of Iraqi civilians Charlie
dagata covered the conflict from the
very beginning we dug up the footage to
prove it there he is 20 years ago he's
now back in Baghdad for this Grim
anniversary Charlie what a consequential
moment in 21st century history good
morning
good morning to you from Baghdad a very
different Baghdad than 20 years ago when
I first came here people were still
living in fear under Saddam Hussein then
the Invasion the fighting the rise and
fall of Isis the violence has now
subsided but it's taken a horrific toll
[Music]
20 years since shock and awe
20 years since that night airstrikes and
cruise missiles lit up the skies Over
Baghdad Paving the way for U.S ground
troops to converge on the capitol
in the first few weeks of the war a
group of Iraqi civilians had gathered
here and began attacking the statue of
Saddam Hussein it was an event that was
shown live on TV screens around the
globe
a U.S marine unit collared the statue
yanking it until it toppled to the
ground the crowd beat it with sticks and
shoes dragging its decapitated head
through the streets it came to symbolize
the collapse of the Saddam regime
in reality the Battle of Iraq had only
just begun
saddam's removal sparked a ferocious
Insurgency and a bloody and prolonged
sectarian conflict we've been through a
lot we saw some things no one should
seem we lived days no one should live
Ahmed al-jaburi was 13 years old when
the country was invaded his wife muja
was nine what was it like here
we were looking for something better we
are looking for a brighter future at
that time for Hope for a hope exactly
hope soon turned to despair one day like
it's very affected me that I opened the
door waiting for my friend to come to go
to go to school and I found two kids
like maybe
four or five years old like in front of
our house the bodies the bodies of two
children muja experienced similar horror
my mom was taking me to school she said
we saw dogs eating the dead bodies and
we'll never forget that in my life
kidnappings and bombings became a daily
occurrence so I still remember the the
shouting and the screaming and the like
the the fire and the smoke everywhere
today the city may feel more secure but
the couple does not I'm waiting for the
next thing to happen really really every
day you wake up in the morning and you
expect the worse every single day yeah
they're determined to stay here they're
expecting their first baby in September
in today's Baghdad the marketplaces are
bustling most of the concrete blast
walls and barbed wire are gone
Iraqis tell us they're determined to put
the country's troubled bloody history
behind them we spoke with U.S ambassador
to Iraq Alina Romanowski who's on a
visit to Washington D.C there's still
much more that all of us could be doing
but I think we're on a a cautiously
optimistic path what's working now that
hasn't been working in the past
well I think there are a number of
things that are working now first of all
I think you have a government that is
committed to
um uh you know improving the lives and
the services for Iraqi people I think
also it is a government that is very
clearly interested in building a future
for for Iraq
after so much Bloodshed and Chaos it may
take years to build that future for Iraq
but two decades after the invasion that
upended this country there is finally
hope that they can
[Music]
now there are some serious challenges
ahead Iran's influence continues to be a
problem in 2500 U.S troops still remain
here top U.S general here told us the
primary role is to ensure that Isis
doesn't reform and launch another attack
on the country glad
Charlie dagada with Monumental reporting
then and now Charlie thank you very much
uh as Charlie points out there's so many
seminal moments from that time first
beginning with Colin Powell appearing
before the U.N in February of 2003
making the case for those weapons of
mass destruction the images that we saw
of saddam's decapitated head the statue
being beaten with the shoes and then in
December of 2003 finding him in that
hole just nine miles outside of secrete
his hometown and pulling him out of that
hole I know but shaky intelligence is is
a pretty bad thing to rest the lives of
hundreds of thousands of civilians and 4
500 American servicemen who volunteered
to go over there and fight I think about
their families today I do too I keep
thinking about the numbers and it's
always more than behind all those
numbers are real people and it's always
we need stories like that to remind us
and I think about the couple that he
just did where he said every day you
wake up expecting the worst yeah imagine
having to live like that right exactly
thank you again